ماسك يطالبوا تحديا ضد الحسابات الوهميه
ويطالبها بمهاجمته وبعد اخبار عن خطفي
واختفى وانتحار الداخليه المصريه تعلن
القبض على بلوجر مصريه بتهمه النصب
وفيلات ريال تعيين مشعوذه في البرلمان
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اذا سنبدا من نشرته
اخبار ايلين ماسك اليوميه واللي عنوانها
اليوم مطالبات بالهجوم
ماسك فاجا متابعيه ومستخدميه تويتر
بتغريده بيطلب فيها من الناس انه تهاجموا
الوحده الاولى الواحد كان بفكر انه هذا
بحث عن الجدل مثلا او انها رساله مبطنه
معناها انه مش فارق معه الحرب اللي شغاله
ضده لكن التركيز شوي يكشف الموضوع
محدد هو موجهها لمين وكاتب في اول تغريده
انها نداء وحاطط الايموجيز اللي شايفينهم
امامكم وطبعا اصدمه مفهوم الحسابات
الوهميه المعروفات بالواتس واللي هي اصلا
كانت سبب اساسي في تعطيل تويتر لفتره
واللي بيوعد هو بانه راح يتخلص منها على
تويتر او على الاقل راح يقللها بنسبه
كبيره اذا ماسك طلب من الواتس فيه تغريده
انهم يهاجموه وبعدين
السبب فيبدوا ان الموضوع كان مجرد اختبار
من ماسك لا جهود تويتر حتى الان في التصدي
للحسابات الوهميه اللي عم نحكي عنها لانه
بعدها بربع ساعه غرد من جديد وقال حلو
كثير الواتس حتى الان مش قادره تطلع
للاعلى في الردود على تغريدتي وقصده
تغريدته وما زالت الاولى والموضوع يعني
انجاز بيقصد في التحكم بالتغريدات اللي
صادره عن حسابات وهميه وانها ما تكون
منتشره بشكل واسع السؤال الان هل يا ترى
هاي هي المفاجاه لمسك من امبارح وقعد فيها
الحسابات الوهميه ولا لسه في شيء ثاني
لانه كان غرد امبارح وقال انه مخبي مفاجاه
للبوتس اليوم
والى جانب المواجهه مع الباص في خبرين عن
مواجهات اخرى لمسك متصدر العناوين اولهم
واجهتهم مع دكتور انفني فوتشي كبير اطباء
البيت الابيض واللي كان من علامات مرحله
كرونه وبستعد للتقاعد نهايه هذا الشهر
ماسك نشا تغريده بيطالب فيها بمحاكمته
والموضوع عمل جدل وانقسام واسع في كثار
ومنهم كثير جمهوريين معه وبيدعموا
مطالباته مطالبات ماسك وكثر منهم
اكثر منهم بيكونوا ديموقراطين كمان ومن
علم العلم بهجموا وبيلتقدوا لتفكير فقط
ماسك وبعد ما اشترك تويتر وقف العمل
بالسياسات اللي كانت متبعه فيها او فيما
يخص تحديدا المعلومات المغلوطه عنه اما
المواجهه الثانيه اللي عم نحكي عنها لمصف
الساعات الماضيه فكانت مش مباشره لكنها
مفاجئه ففي مجموعه تسريبات الجديده اللي
عم تنشر عن اداره تويتر السابقه وطورتها
في امور كثيره انتشرت امبارح نسخه جديده
من الملفات وهذا الجزء بيحكي عن تورط جهات
واشخاص في الضغط على تويتر لاحظره ترامب
والمفاجاه كانت في الناس اللي قيل انها
متواصلوا مع تويتر وضغطوا عليها على راسهم
كانت السيده الاولى السابقه اوباما
والملفات كشفت كمان كيف تويتر غيرت
سياساتها
متعمده لتخليها بتسمح لها انها تحضر ترامب
شكلها كامل
انطلق يوم الخميس معرض جده للكتاب 2022
مستمره حتى 17 ديسمبر وبتضمن البرنامج
الثقافي اكثر من 100 فعاليه وبتشمل
الجلسات الحواريه والامسيات الشعريه كمان
ورش عمل واقتصاديه مجموعه من المتحدثين
السعوديين
البارزين في مختلف المجالات هذا كله
بالاضافه الى مجموعه من المناطق والاجنحه
المتنوعه مثل ركن خالص للمؤلف السعودي
يشمل اكثر من 400
للمؤلفين ذوي النشر ذاتي واجنحه على الكتب
الصوتيه ومكتبه رقميه وجلسات ومناطق
وغيرها
ركن اخر من اركان معرض جده للكتاب الحالي
ملفت للانتباه وعمل تفاعل واسع هو منطقه
الخير العلمي المره الاولى اللي حدث عربي
فقط
مصممه بشكل اسباب المركبه الفضائيه وبتضمن
اركان تعريفيه للادب الخيال العلمي واللي
بيلقى رواج واهتمام كبير كثير عند مختلف
فئات العمريه هذا كله بالاضافه الى مجموعه
من الفعاليات والانشطه ومن ابرزها مؤتمر
الخيال العلمي ايضا المؤتمر كان من ايام
مستمر يومين وهو الاول من نوعه في
السعوديه في تفاعلكم احنا حبينا ناخذكم في
الجو
تحديدا في هذه المنطقه اللي احنا بنحكي
عنها منطقه الخيال العلمي فمعنى من مقر
معرض جده للكتاب مراسل العربيه عبد الواحد
الحميد اهلا بك يا عبد الواحد همم يعني
معرض ميز على ما يبدو
باقسام جديده همم هذا العام مثل القسم
اللي عم نحكي عنه قسم الخيال العلمي حدثنا
اكثر وخذنا بجوله هيك خلينا نشوف هذا
القسم بعيوننا لانه بالفعل قسم متميز
همم
في بعض الكتاب هذه النسخه النسخه مختلفه
من حيث الفعاليات الثقافيه والاقسام
المتنوعه اللي كانت مختلفه بعض الشيعه
السابقه تحديدا في منطقه الخيال العلمي
اللي تجاهدونها خلفي هذا هو المدخل الخاص
المنطقه اللي همم يعني تشهد اقبال كبير من
همم مختلف الفئات هذه المنطقه يحضر فيها
يعني كل من هو مهتم بالخيال العلمي فيها
طبعا اقسام متنوعه ومختلفه همم من خلال
المقتنيات اللي موجوده همم
طبعا مقتنيات نادره من افلام ومسلسلات
خاصه
بالخيال العلمي اضافه الى همم الاقسام
الاخرى مثل همم
الشخصيات همم طبعا همم وكذلك حتى مساحه
القراءه الخاصه هذه هي الاقسام الثلاثه
الرئيسيه الموجوده في هذا القسم وهذه
المنطقه اللي تقام لاول مره في معارض
الكتب في السعوديه همم في هذا المنطقه
استديو صناعه الشخصيه همم يتم همم العمل
على همم تعلم رسم الشخصيات همم المشاركين
من الاطفال حسب التكنيكات معينه همم
معتمده طبعا في هذا القسم همم تتم
المشاركه بشكل مستمر من قبل الاطفال
المشاركين في هذه همم المنطقه همم طبعا
وكذلك هذه الجزيره في منطقه الخيال العلمي
همم اللي هي مساحه القراءه همم اللي تعتمد
القراءه الجماعيه تحديدا للاطفال
والموجودين في همم هذا القسم من خلال
مشاركه ما يقراون في معرض الكتاب في هذه
النسخه يعني هذه ابرز التفاصيل راويه
المتعلقه في هذه المنطقه تحدي المنطقه
العلميه
عن بقيه الاقسام حسب ما همم يعني عرفنا
بانه حتى هناك قسم خاص بالنشر الذاتي همم
يعني خصوصا الناشر السعودي اللي قام بنشر
الذاتي بعيدا عن دور النشر وهذه طريقه
جديده بالنشر يمكن همم احنا ما تعودنا
عليها
حدثنا اكثر عن هذا الجانب وجوانب اخرى
يعني متميزه في همم المعرض خصوصا الاقبال
عليه
ومفهوم جديد في معارض الكتب همم موجود في
معرض جدا للكتاب مبادرات ومشاريع سعوديه
تعتمد نشر الذاتي من خلال همم يعني
الاعتماد بشكل مباشر واختصار مسافه العمل
من خلال العمل مع المطابع مباشره دون
الحاجه الى همم يعني وكلاء نشر ودور النشر
وهذه السلسله الطويله هذه ال- ال- يعني
المبادره اللي موجوده في معرض جده الكتاب
وكانت موجوده كذلك في معرض الرياض يتم من
خلالها تسهيل العمليه اكثر يعني انا شفت
بعض دور نشر الموجوده والمطابع والمشاريع
الموجوده اللي تحت فكره النشره الذاتي همم
يعني حتى في بعض الاقسام يعني في قسم
موجود هنا عنده حتى الطابعات ويطبع في
خلال عشر دقائق ممكن تطلع النسخه همم اذا
كان عندك حقوق همم
اضافه الى طبعا الفعاليات الثقافيه واللي
ما حكينا عنها يعني كان في همم
استثنائيه يعني مختلفه شويه يعني كان في
شخصيات همم تمت استضافتها من ممثلين من
مسلسل جيم اوف ثرونز وكذلك من سترينجرز
وغيرها من الفعاليات اللي موجوده يعني حتى
مثلا الفعليات اللي كانت تناقش الافلام
سواء كانت الافلام السعوديه وحتى يعني
الافلام الاجنبيه الافلام الخيال العلمي
مؤتمر الخيال العلمي راويه وكان يناقش
كذلك موضوعات لاول مره في همم يعني في هذه
النسخه من همم معرض جدا للكتاب
ههه شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الواحد الحميد
مشاهدينا كان معنا من مقر المعرض جده
للكتاب شكرا لك
هدير عاطف بلوجر مصري بيتابعها الملايين
صحيح لكن فيكتور ما كانوا بيعرفوها قبل ما
يتصدر اسمها التراند والعناوين اليوم هدير
عندها حساب على انستغرام يتابعها عليه
مليونين ونصف شخص وبتعرف عنه وبتعرف عن
حالها في بانها بلوجر موضه ستايل سفر
امبارح بالليل وفجاه انتشر فيديو بشكل
واسع للوالدتها هدير
والناس بانقاب بنتها اللي بحسب كلامها
انا بنتي من الساعه 7:00 انا شفت سياده
الرئيس وبلاشف الهديه النائب العام بلاكوا
سايبه بنت دخلوا علينا بلطجيه
مخده وخدوا كل حاجه وسابت في القلب عندها
ثقه في القلب وعندها مشاكل في القلب عندنا
مشاكل سيبوها واخذوا ابنتي اخذوني بنتي
الساعه 7:00 الصبح لحد دلوقتي انت مش
عارفه فين مش عارفه كده انا قلت له لا في
الشارع
[موسيقى]
حب عمري
40 40 العام والنمل كله اخذ ذهب واخذ
الفلوس وخدوا كل حاجه هي اجزتها الوحيده
اللي هي اتجوزت واحد وحش
بيشتغل
وحش بيشتغل في اي حاجه خذوا بنتي وحققوا
معه لو لقيته على حاجه تستاهل يضرب بنتي
ما عليهاش حاجه خالص واتطلقت منه قبرته عن
كل حاجه
[موسيقى]
مع فيديو الام والاستغاثه هذه طلع زوجها
لهدير بلال ذيب قلب الدنيا بستوريات فيها
كلام مش مفهوم عن عقود وفلوس واقسام شرطه
وفي لستوريات كمان هدد بالانتحار وقال
كمان عشر دقائق مش راح مش هاكون موجود في
الحياه وانا لله وانا اليه راجعون وكاتب
حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل كذا مره وكلام كثير
ثاني فعليه مش مفهوم وقال كمان بلال الحق
وهدير وهدير قائله في رقبتكم وانه ما بقى
ما اعرفش او ما بعرف هدير وين ولا بنته
هايله البنت طبعا اللي شفناها قبل شويه في
الفيديو مع ام هادير توصيلتين اخرى ياتين
عن بلال مشاهدينا قبل ما احكي لكم
المفاجاه الكبرى
عليه 300,000 وشويه تحول من عام الى حساب
خاص ومسكر قدام اللي ما بتابعهم
ثانيا هو وهدير كانوا اواخر الشهر الماضي
اعلن طلاقم وهدير حتى نصحت كل صورهم من
حسابها هذه تفصيله مهمه كثير لما تسمعوه
بقيه القصه فمن بعد اللي كل اللي سمعته
وشفتوه والكلام عن اختفاء واختطاف وانتحار
وفلوس المفاجاه صادمه كانت اعلان السلطات
بالقبض على هدير والتهمه
قال اسمها هدير وزوجها صراحه لكنه قال
بلوجر ازياء والناس والاعلام استنتجوا
انها هدير بين الداخليه قال انها تلقت
بلاغات من 16 مواطن ضد البلوجر وزوجها
وشقيقته وزوجها تتهمهم بالنصب والاحتيال
عليه والتحصل على مبالغ
ماليهم بيملكوا مجموعه شركات تعمل في مجال
العقارات والسيارات والتداول المالي
وقالوا لهم انه راح يستثمروا لهم الفلوس
مقابل ارباح نتيجه وقال بيانه داخليه انه
البلوجر حتى هو جاءت حسبها على انستغرام
لانشطه الشركات بين متابعيها وداخليه
اعلنت القبض على ثلاثه من المتهمين
الاربعه اللي اعترفوا بتلقي اموال من
المجني عليهم قيمتها اكثر من مليون جنيه
بحجه استثمارها مقابل ارباح لكنهم لا
قدموا ارباح ولا ردوا للناس اصل المبلغ
اصلا وخاتمه الداخليه بيانها بانها تم
اتخاذ الاجراءات القانونيه والصوره اللي
نشرتها الداخليه ومع انها مش واضحه كثير
ومش مبينه والوجوه تحديدا لكن واضح انه
فيها سيدتين ورجل وناس قالوا اكيد هدير
وحده منهم اما هل الرجل في الصوره هو
زوجها او زوج اخته فهذا مش معروفه بيان
الداخليه ايضا اكتفى بالتاكيد انه الجهود
مستمره للقبض على المتهم الهارب من دون
توضيح هويته وهو هون لافته انه نذكر انه
يعني داخليه قال بلوفر ازياء وزوجها بينما
مثل ما قلنا هم اعلنوا من فتره طلائهم
وثاني اللي الناس كثير انتبهت له هو انه
على صور هدير على انستقرام ومن اسابيع في
كومنتات بتتكرروا من حسابات مختلفه بتقول
لها رجعي فلوسنا وبتوصفها بالنصابه كمان
في سيده من جنوب افريقيا اسمها مونديليا
وعمرها 36 سنه عايشه من كده سنه في
نيوزيلندا مع اسرتها واطفالها ولما قدمت
على اقامه دائمه طلبها
القصه عادي وبصير يعني لا كثير ناس لكن
الجزئيه الغريبه في سبب الرفض الحكومه
نيوزلنديا رافضه طلب الاقامه بسبب وزن
السيد الزائد وقالت لها لو بدك تضلي عايشه
في نيوزيلندا وتاخدي اقامه لازم تنزلي
وزنك 30 كيلو او تغادر الاراضي المنزليه
السبب بحسب المستندات الرسميه انه وزنها
زائد هذا راح يخليها للامراض اكثر ولا
المشاكل الصحيه وبالتالي ممكن تشكل عيده
على النظام الصحي في نيوزيلندا كل
نيوزيلندا راح يصير عيب من سيده واحده
يعني زائد وزنها على كل حال مندلينا هو
وزنها تقريبا على
قرار واخذت اعفاء واقامه بعد ما نزلت
وزنها ونسبه الدهون في جسمها حوالي 10
نقاط واستغلت اللي صار لبدا رحله لانزال
الوزن وبتشاركها مع متابعيها على حساباتها
وبتتمرن خمس مرات في الاسبوع لكن من هون
لوقتها يبدو انها حابه تستفيد من الدرج
الاعلاميه اللي يعملها الموضوع واعلانات
مؤخرا انها راح تبدا في العمل كعارضه
ازياء كمان من صاحبات الوزن الزائد
خلينا نروح على تركيا
ميزانيه وزاره الاسره والخدمات الاجتماعيه
والصحه والداخليه للعامل المقبل صار في
فوضى عجيبه كثير خلونا نشوف
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الفيديو الفيديو
لاعضاء حزب المعارضه ووصفهم بابناء امريكا
طول الموضوع اكثر بكثير خلينا نشوف
[تصفيق]
سلام
احنا طبعا مش فاهمين شيء بس واضح انهم
زعلانين من بعض يعني
تحديدا والصراخ ورمي الورق على الوزير
البث الرسمي لجلسه البرلمان على قناته
انقطع لكن حاضرين صوروا وانتشر الفيديو
على فكره هذا تشابك جاي بعد اسبوع تقريبا
المشهد اخر مشابه جدا بس يمكن كان اشد
وطاه خلال جلسه ايضا كانت بتناقش
الميزانيه اشتبك النواب وبلعيده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اشتباك بالايدي مثل ما شفته كان اعنف من
اشتباك اليوم اعنف لا درج لانه نائب حسين
اوريس من حزب الخير المعارض وبعد ما اخذ
بوكس على راسه خلال لقناه المستشفى مسكين
ووضع في العنايه المشدده وانقال انه عنده
اضطراب في ضربات القلب وضعه حرج الملفت
انه بعد كل هذا تم قبول الموازنات الحمد
لله اللي كان الخلاف هذا كله بسببها
ومن برلمان تركيا
وخبر عجيب غريب بصراحه عالم السحر
والشعوذه يعني موجود وبنسمع عنه اخبار
عادي لكن انه نسمع انه سحر والشعوذه في
عالم السياسه كمان
والانتقادات
الساحره مثل ما قلت لكم شهيره ومعروفه
بلقب الساحره البيضاء واسمها سانيتيا
بيتري وبتعرف عن حالها بانها معالجه بدها
ستايل خاصه
الاحجار الكريمه وعندها القدره على القضاء
على الطاقه السلبيه وتحويل على طاقه
ايجابيه وشهرتها مش بسبب اعمالها او عملها
هذا لكنها كمان هي نفسها مش بعيده عن
السياسه فسنيطه سبق وترشحت لمجلس النواب
لكن ما نجحت في الانتخابات
وحزبها اللي هو نفس حزب النائب اللي
عينتها لتساعدها الحزب سماها مرشحته مره
لمنصب وزيره الرعايه
تقريبا اما الجدل والانتقادات كلها لا
تعيينها الساحره طلعت بنفسها وردت وقالت
مستغربه الا يمكن للساحره ان تكون في
البرلمان يعني واكدت انها واللي مثلها
مفيدين ومهمين جدا في عالم السياسه وانه
الكثير من زملائها بيعملوا اصلا في المجال
السياسي وانا بقول اشي كثير والله بتشوفك
كثير على كل حال مشاهدينا وصلنا لختام
تفاعل لكم اشكركم حسن المتابعه
[موسيقى]